they give you coordinates and the first
thing you should do is only write down
six three if you don't mind me writing
in red it's just okay it's alright good
so that's bright now we want that sorry
we put the midpoint okay right so I'm
gonna begin by quoting the formula
I'm just quitting before me that doesn't
get any marks ready but it helps you it
helps you work out okay what am I going
to put my all my numbers into so I'll
write down the formula first I think you
should write the formula until you can
get it right without quoting it so I've
been I've written at thousands of times
I feel really comfortable with it I
still like to write at some times just
so I make sure I don't screw it up I
definitely think for this introductory
exercise you should write it out because
that's one of the cool ways to forever
okay now let's go through it one step at
a time
x1 and x2 one of those numbers on our on
our powerpoints it'll be now be really
careful okay
if it helps you what you can do is you
can label each one before you actually
start with the min I would label the
x1y1 and x2y2 okay
you got next and why and then you've got
another extra Y okay so now can you see
a bit clearer up which values are X 1 X
2 1 3 1 of 3 good so we write that down
1 plus 3 and now we'll do the same for
the Y values so it's gonna be 6 plus 4 4
plus 6 like so
okay they're really nice easy doubles to
work with so I'm going to get 402 and 10
over 2 so I find the light is what's the
answer
it's I can simplify right wait so they
have 4 divided by 2 2 that's 210 divided
by 2 that's the it yeah that's it that's
it now you don't have to do this I'll
just quickly illustrate for you like is
this correct well you can actually tell
that's the great thing about all of
these kinds of formulas you can see
whether you're right or not if I plot
all of these points on let's have a go 1
6 that'll be somewhere up here 1 6 so
that would make 3/4 about here so now if
I join them up and try to my wizard big
boys there we go
that would be the midpoint and sure
enough it lines up with 2 5 go bad okay
so this one is really easy to use and
you can check whether you are right or
not by drawing a rough sketch yes you
can yes you can
if provided the numbers are nice and
easy provided the numbers are nice and
easy but if they're number one if
they're if they're weird values like you
know fraction the decimals while that
kind of thing
that way Kahana number two as you get
further into maths um you don't just
deal with points that have just nice
neat numbers like that you deal with
points where the numbers themselves are
like variables which is really weird in
which case you can't draw a diagram
because you're like where is this I
don't know it can change no single
diagram will convey that so then you
have to know this so you can deal with
it even if a diagram can't explain it
it's that kind of make sense so number
one just in case you get hard numbers
number two we're trying to pave the way
for what's going to come in the future
where this is a useful
- no okay